Is everybody keeping cool today?
It's really hot outside.
Super hot.
Sticking sweat.
Yeah, it's really good.
It's like, you just sweat looking at it.
I'm just so hot right now.
It's so gross.
Hey, is there a back end to your fucking joke?
No, just wanted to say hi, it's hot outside?
What kind of cold open is this?
It's a hot open.
Welcome to Smartless.
Smartless.
JPM, I'm across the street from you.
Yeah, no.
I know.
What do you mean?
So wait, so you're up top, right?
All the way up top.
I'm at top.
Did you ask?
What was the question?
Sorry.
Yeah.
Okay.
So I think I can see you.
You can see me.
I'm not in the window.
Wait, are you being serious?
Can you see the scaffolding?
Yeah.
What's going on up there?
Are we doing some remod?
Do you see like a black bag on the scaffolding that's blowing in the wind?
No.
Because I'm on the south side of the building.
South side of your building.
Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
So on the south side of the building,
way up there, there's like a little black bag.
No, because the whole building is netted,
so I don't see that.
Oh, you don't see through the netting.
No, I don't.
Anywho, so we're neighbors.
We've never lived closer to one another.
I know.
Actually, no, that when you lived in my house with me and my wife.
That was so fun.
Why does my youngest daughter look so much like you?
This is before the kids, and the, God, your floors are so creaky,
and I was just always, like, at night, just like,
I didn't want to make a sound as I snuck around.
Oh, cigarettes.
I was smoking back then, too, though, wasn't I?
You sure were.
Hey, why is your hair so cut?
Yeah, it looks cool.
I just had a little Tremski.
Is Eli with you right now?
No, I didn't see Eli.
I went to see my boy, my guy, Kevin Woon.
Why, wait, are you in a fight with Eli?
No, no, no, I just haven't seen Eli.
And, uh...
What happened to Eli and you?
No.
Well...
I love Eli, you know, if you're like...
So, wait.
Now, Sean also has a personal hairdresser.
Sean, who's your, you've got a new person, who's your person?
Yeah, his name is Marcos.
Hey, hashtag relatable, you both have personal hairdressers?
No, it's the, no, it's not personal.
They're not full-time employment, you jerk.
Yeah, kind of.
The payroll, no.
Who cuts your hair?
Whoever is heading the hair department on whatever project I'm working.
That's a lie.
As a matter of fact, she just left the apartment.
She is the key hairdresser on the, yeah.
And she came over to the house, huh?
She did.
You're not even in the cast this time.
You're the director.
so she had to come to the director's out.
So now who's high...
That's so inky.
That's so in front of those high pollutant.
I'm doing one small scene which qualifies as a free cut.
His legs are broken so he couldn't come to me.
So I had to go to the director's apartment down in fancy part of Manhattan.
Okay?
So, Sean, you're enjoying your new hairdresser?
I am.
He's really, really good.
Marcos, yeah.
So much so that you won't take your hat off.
Yeah, take your head off.
Let's see what Marco is doing to you.
Well, it's just, you know, look like...
Back on. Back on?
Like Will said it looked like a page boy.
I didn't say that. I just said it looked like your hair is attached.
On Saturday night, you said I looked like a page boy.
Oh, on Saturday.
And I said, were you going for...
What scientist? Mad scientist?
Because your hair was...
My hair was longer, because it was all sticking out.
And you said, did you say, did you just say to them give me the mad scientist?
Yes.
And so, Will, you've got to...
That's why I cut my hair because Sean shamed me.
Is that true?
Or is it just like a summer sort of...
Or you...
is it swim team it looks good short like that well you know what i can't believe that you would
habitually chew gum on a fucking podcast i know i mean i'm nervous just he just it wasn't by the way it's
not loud the way i'm doing it you've gotten better at that but it still sneaks through and i'll bet
you all speak for rob and benet right here it's getting annoying having to mute your microphone every
once in a while benet rob tell me is it true we tidy it up you know what you know what people have nicotine
I have a special relationship with Bennett, Rob, who may love me.
And nicotine.
You know what?
Our coffee chat's real hyper today.
It is.
I think it's my fault.
I love it.
I'm having one now, too.
I'm having the rare 1 p.m. coffee.
We're in a real Regis and Kathy Lee areas.
We're lucky.
Lucky to be associated.
All right.
Do you want to get on with it?
Yeah.
I mean, I don't know.
Do you want to tee up your intro?
Yeah.
How about you guys?
Let's have an official guest.
session here okay okay okay okay let's see if you guys can guess it all right okay great um joining our nonsense
today is a fellow who's not yet 40 but is already approaching the 20 year mark with his band okay
they are Grammy winners they are known and loved worldwide he was born in california but raised in
England he's got three children with his wife who has been a guest on this very podcast I know
who it is let's fucking hear it it's um Chris Martin no no
It's Marcus Mumford.
Bingo.
Get out.
How about that?
How about that for a guest?
How did you know that?
Because he's a smart person.
Marcus, I liked my hints.
Can I get on with my hands?
No, your hints were terrible.
I didn't know where he's born in California.
Well, but his band sounds like a family, law firm specializing personal injury.
You didn't even say it?
Personal injury.
It does sound like.
It sounds like a plumbing company.
Monfort in time.
It does.
That was on purpose, right, Marcus?
No, but Marcus, I knew I was just.
talking about I'm so excited for the doc
and I was just talking about you
10 minutes ago so excited to come and see it
yeah are you gonna come yeah man
are you gonna come oh sweet it's just down
the street I might I might
be working but I might be able to make it
I think my wife will be there which
that's all anybody ever cares about she's my date
have you ever
guest a guest
from their laugh
before they've done the reveal
because I was really they freak me out man
your guys freak
me out there like, don't breathe.
Oh, really?
Until the reveal.
And I wanted to laugh because you're very funny.
Did they make you think that we're
like, that we're prone to rage?
Like if we hear the guest?
No, they made me feel, you know, in a very polite way,
like I would ruin the entire show if I
in sure.
It's squeak.
The whole surprise thing is so,
it's such a waste. It just saves us
from doing homework. And the audience
already knows who it is.
We're the only two dicks that don't know who the guest is,
the time the episode is up.
I don't dare you refer to me as the dick.
But listen, it's fun.
We're having fun.
Okay, Jason.
Fun, look into it.
Okay.
Marcus, welcome to SmartList.
It's about time.
I'm so, I'm genuinely so on, I was early on Smartis.
I was very early.
You came, you came to the show in L.A.
I remember you and I, we went to an early screening of Maestro together.
We did, yeah.
And you said, and it was, it was really,
right after our show and you said, I came to the show
and I said, I was so surprised.
It was the night you guys were filming
and it was really hectic.
Wait, was it, you mean like the L.A. show?
Yeah.
In the dock?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
The one downtown.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
At the theater.
I can't remember what it's called.
And I didn't want to bother you
because it was super hectic.
But yes, I came to the show.
And I've been, but I've been listed your show
for a very long time.
It's crazy.
You're ready for notes.
Do you have any news?
notes. What would you do? If you were us, how would you change it?
We're looking to improve. You know what? Here the hash shit was a low point I think.
Yeah. It's a, it's all low points. What we do is, what we do is we establish the bar low early, right?
And then everything feels like a win. The only way is up. I love it. It's just very cozy. I love it.
I tell you something, Mark, what's interesting, you brought up something and we're about to tap into a runner
thematically is that you told me that you were at the show. And I think, you told me that you were at the show.
and I vaguely remember at the time
sort of saying, I wish you had said hi
and then you just mentioned it was hectic
and you didn't want to say hi
you came to our show
and didn't come backstage and say hi
and Jason has thoughts on this
Hold on this is
we're not talking Broadway theater
Yeah let's do it right
I need your opinion on this
It's adjacent
I went to see
Do you know who I went to see last week
in Exeter was Tim Key
Now do you know Tim Key?
Oh yeah he's brilliant
He's one of my favorite comics of all time
I think he's a genius.
I went and watched his show and was about to leave and thought to myself,
now he knows I'm here, he helped with the tickets.
It is rude to leave.
Well, that's different.
If someone has helped you with the ticket.
Amen.
Without saying great show.
So how about this, right?
So you are a musician and you are in live venues and theaters.
And so there are some famous people that come see your shows a lot.
Here we go.
Does the same rule apply there?
Are you aware who's in there?
Are you offended if they don't come back and say, hey, great show?
No.
Culturally very different in music.
Very different.
I'm more of a rock and roll guy at heart, guys.
Wait, what's your position, Jason?
Are you a no show?
Are you a no show at the show?
I think it's presumptuous for people in the audience who are famous or even pseudo-famous
to think that, oh, they'll be welcome backstage just because you share fame.
to come say hi.
It's just like it's so arrogant.
Like just get hell out.
It's more like you probably want to see me
because I'm really famous, so I'll bless you with my presence.
Yeah, and let you know how great I think you were.
Or not.
Or talk about how great the program was, or the lighting,
or find something polite to say.
There's that famous clip from the Madonna documentary Truth or Dare
when Kevin Costner comes backstage.
Did you see that?
And he goes, yeah, I thought,
and she just spent three hours.
She's drenched in sweat, you know, performing for 5,000 people.
And he goes, he says, yeah, we thought it was really neat.
Yeah, yeah.
And she turns to the camera, she goes, anybody who calls my show neat has got to go.
Right in front of them.
No, he left and she goes, ah, like that on camera.
My favorite backstage moment like that when I was invited, very explicitly invited backstage,
was after Kendrick Lamar played Bonnery.
and there was a sort of message
that came down from on high
that Kendrick would like to see you
and when Kendrick calls you come
right because he's the king
I learned that lesson the hard way
and it was like you can go in now
and
and he took off almost all of his clothes
as I walked in it was amazing
it sounds more like boneroo
we'll be right back after these messages
it was amazing and I thought
like the gum the gumption you know the gumption to be like yeah come on back after the show and it'll be
the very moment when i take all my clothes off and i'm just down to my undies it's confident we'll have a
chat i don't know i kind of feel but but aren't you comfortable with that like like even on a on a tv set
or a film set or whatever people knock on my trailer i'm like come in i'm dressing i don't care it is a
dressing room yeah yeah yeah that is you know marcus you bring up uh tim kee whom i also adore and he did that
incredible film with your wife.
Did.
The Ballad of Wallace Island, which I
loved that film.
I did too.
Brilliant, brilliant film, wasn't it?
We're not going to get into Carrie's
career, but it, I mean,
amazing.
Good, because I haven't seen a lot of it, but that one I've seen
three times.
I love that one so much.
So, me too. You guys, I urge
anybody to see The Ballad of Wallace Island.
It's such a beautiful little film.
It's so funny and poignant and just
amazing, beautiful, beautiful film.
Well, I got so into Tim's
podcast. He's got like a radio
for, it's not a podcast, it's a radio
show in the UK on
public radio and I got so
deeply into it in COVID that when he
wrote to Kerry with a script I was like
you absolutely have to do this movie
he's, him and Tom Bazden together
are phenomenal.
Tom Baden amazing too. Yeah,
amazing. And just for my sister, your
wife is Carrie Mulligan. Just so for Tracy
my sister in case she doesn't know. Hi Tracy.
Tracy almost crashed
She was trying to look at all.
You know.
Hey, Siri.
She's pulling into Kohler, Wisconsin
with her phone in her head.
Wait, so Marcus, getting back to that for one quick second,
she can't possibly see all your shows
because you're playing almost every night.
No, she actually broke a record.
So are you allowed to not see all of hers?
Yeah, yeah, she came on tour.
I think she, in one year, maybe was at.
48 shows
and watched
two.
Not the whole thing.
Top and tail.
Yeah.
She really
she really
she says she likes our
band, our recorded music.
There's some caveats.
First time she saw our band play
she thought we were quite shouty.
And to be fair, I think she's right about that.
But then, you know, she's put up
with it for a long time. But then, yeah,
She doesn't feel like if she's on the road
She has to come to every show
Wait Marcus, did you guys meet at summer camp?
Am I right about that?
Yeah, we met at Bible camp
Yeah, when we were like,
I was 10, she was 12.
What?
Nice, wow, yeah, nice.
So you guys were, now she started to tell some of the story
I think I remember when she was on about her.
They were pen pals, right?
Yeah, you guys were pen pals.
Yeah, and she still has the journal entry
from the day we met where my cousin was there
who was two years older,
who was age appropriate for her,
and he got a eight and a half out of ten.
But I, who was definitely not underlined boyfriend material, got a nine out of ten.
Wow.
Go figure.
So then what made you not boyfriend material because you were just...
I was two years younger and I was also a foot shorter.
Oh, it wasn't because you were some...
It wasn't because you were a monster running around and being a pair of years.
No, well, she did write in her journal that I was a bit aggressive
on the soccer pitch
that I've gone in a bit heavy on some of the tackles
which lines up
but then we stayed in touch as kids
I guess and then we reconnected in our 20s
and did you lighten up are you still a heavy tackler
or I mean let's
yes
it's one of the few times I'll drop a sea bomb
in earnest
is co-ed soccer in the states particularly
I lived in Denver
and I used to play co-ed soccer
and you know you can't retaliate
at least where I come from
you know a woman tackles you really hard
you can't retaliate
so yeah I get
yeah so the rage comes out on the football field
sometimes
oh god
it's a big big game on right now
Willie I bet you're taking you
I know I know I'm guys whoever organized this
I know I can't believe we've done this
I know I'm watching it I've got it too
I just turned it off
but don't spoil it right
because I haven't
I'm going to watch it afterwards.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's really intriguing right now, by the way.
It's really intriguing.
I haven't got a live feed because I was thinking about it.
And then I didn't press record.
Should we take a break?
Are you in the UK?
Marcus, are you in the UK or are you here?
Yeah, and so I thought on Champions League Final Day,
we'd be safe to do a chat at 5 or 6.
Turns out it was an early kickoff.
5 o'clock.
But do you honestly want to take a two-second break and go hit record
so you can see the second half?
I'll
Do it on your phone, yeah, for sure
No, no, no, no
Don't worry about it
It's fine
If it was an England game
So we have a
We have a fairly new management team
Last couple years
And who's we?
They haven't managed us through a...
They haven't managed
Sorry, band management
Oh, okay
They haven't managed our band
Through a World Cup summer
And it's a big deal
Trying to manage
Our band during a World Cup summer
Because if there's any kind of
We tend not to play on England days
Because they're big days
I take this stuff very seriously.
And I sat them all down for the third time in about February.
We delayed the announcement of our tour
because they hadn't yet announced what dates and days
the group games were going to be.
And so business-wise, it was almost a disaster.
But we waited for so long
because we waited to announce the tour
so that we knew we weren't going to be on stage
when England were playing, right?
And I sat everyone down.
I said, look, guys, management's going great.
You're doing a really good job.
But just so you know,
we've had this conversation now three times.
I'm deadly serious.
If you double book us when England are playing,
everyone is fired.
Everyone is fired.
And I think they've got the message pretty clear now.
And I think I'm going to manage to sneak to a couple of games.
But it's a big summer.
It's a big summer.
Yeah.
So let's go back to being a kid.
And we're right in there around summer camp.
Where did you grow up?
Jason said you grew up in California?
No, I was born in California.
Oh, you're born, okay.
But evacuated to England at six months old.
Oh, so not even.
And I grew up in London.
What were the conditions under which you were born in California?
Why is that?
My parents were working there for a couple of years down in Anaheim for a church.
And so I was born, I popped up along the way.
And then they came back home to plant a church in London from the Californian one.
God, and then at what point then was me?
music introduced to you?
Yeah, I mean, it was the kitchen.
My mom listened to a lot of music and had a vinyl collection that I was allowed access to quite early on.
And then we would listen to music.
What were some of those vinals?
What was a lot of classical music and a lot of choral music?
Because she was in a choir at university and stuff.
That's cool.
And then the only two kind of pop records she had or non-classical records were Blood on the Tracks.
Amazing.
And House of the Rising Sun by the Animals.
Wow.
Oh, wow.
And so I played them to death.
And then we leaned heavily into the greatest hits by Bruce Springsteen.
That was like the family car record.
So that explains that you don't have an aversion or rather you have an attraction to
or an ability to incorporate these other instruments and instrumentation around your music.
Some people call it folk.
I know that that's not really accurate.
But the fact that you can work in all these different sense.
sounds and your music, your sound, the band's sound, is so full and varied.
Agreed.
Does that have some roots in the classical music that you were all the multiple instruments?
Yeah, maybe.
I think that's partly a reflection of the taste that, you know, amongst the band members.
Like me and Ben and Ted all have real different tastes in music, and it covers most genres.
Ben, like Ted's the best guitar, he's the bass player, he's the best guitarist in the band by a long way.
He plays jazz and blues and kind of studied it.
but plays the bass in the band
which is very kind of kind
actually and then Ben grew up
playing lots of classical and jazz on piano
and saxophone he was a better drummer than me at school
and then
I you know yeah we cover
most of the genres together
and I think we've always felt like
whatever instruments suit the song that we're writing
at the time right you know
so we leaned heavily into like electric guitars
and stuff on the third and fourth records
and now I've kind of come back more
to the acoustic stuff and it's just fun
man. We love it.
We'll be right back.
And now back to the show.
What about you playing so many different instruments?
That's not super common, right?
Well, the key is learning three chords on lots of instruments.
Yeah, but I mean, playing drums is so not the same as playing a guitar.
What's more difficult?
It seems like the drums would be very difficult to master, or is it just...
Well, I mean, that was my instrument at school, and I took it for.
fairly seriously and did the grading system.
And that started with pots and pans in the kitchen,
my mom and dad.
And then I played all the way through high school.
I played at college just for the year that I lasted at college.
And then got hired as a drummer in a band.
So I quit college.
For Laura Marling, yeah.
So I quit college, go play for Laura.
Well done.
And that was my first job in music.
And that's really nice.
And so I got hired as a session drummer,
and I still like to play drums for people when I get the chance, honestly,
because I love it.
And then I learned open tunings on the guitar
so that I could play it like a percussion instrument, really,
without having to read...
I can read drum music.
I can't read, you know, other music.
Oh, really?
Does drum music look like?
Yeah.
It's still on a stave.
Yeah, there's X's and there's Nauts and Crosses, basically.
And so, like, the snare is an X,
and the kick drum is a...
Yeah, the kick...
The bass drum goes at the bottom,
and then the snare is like two down,
you know, where the C would normally be.
And the hi-hats are on top,
and they're normally X's,
and then the symbols are on top of that.
They stack it on the way.
So, you know, the note?
Like, there's a line...
Yeah.
And the black dot.
Instead, it's a line with an X, and that's percussion.
For symbols, it's an X.
Yeah.
Huh.
Wait, Jason and Will, did you guys ever...
Did you ever...
Try to learn an instrument or no?
Piano, I played as a little kid,
and then when I got too big to be pushed around,
I said, I'm out.
Yeah, sure, I understand that.
So you always had a great attitude.
Is that what you're saying?
You're consistent.
No, it was, it wasn't, it wasn't like.
I wish I had.
I wish I'd stayed with him.
But, you know, it's like, my parents, like they said,
you know, like it's a form of discipline.
You're going to have to do your practice for an hour.
every single day.
Yeah, yeah.
So they made it fun.
Exactly.
Like that was a problem.
Like, you know, they should have made it fun.
Like any kid, you're going to try to cheat and not practice.
And so they set up a tape recorder that I had to put on the piano and press record during my one hour practice to prove that I was practicing.
Of course, it was the same music that I was practicing each and every week.
So you just record it once and just turn that in.
Record it once.
And they bought it.
You know, you're not getting any better by Friday each week.
Yeah.
That was your audition for It's Your Move.
That sounds like the thing
of your character
and It's Your Move would have done.
The show Jason did when he was like 15.
It was so funny, Marcus,
I played over here.
It was a brilliant show
where he just played a kid
who did shit like that all the time.
I wish, yeah, I wish I had,
I did a couple instruments here and there
during school and I wish,
I just wish I'd stuck with it.
It's one of those, like I wish I'd,
I can play four chords on a guitar really sloppily.
I just...
But let me ask you this, Marcus,
to that, to Will's point is like,
once you learn and become proficient as you have in so many areas of music
and not only music singing and all that,
is you don't listen to other music the same way.
Yeah, that's true.
Whereas somebody like Will or Jay who...
I love music.
Yeah, you have a different appreciation for it,
not that you don't if you know it, but, you know, it's just a different ear.
We had this conversation the other day we had a party at home.
It was Carrie's birthday.
And someone came and they were like, there's no music.
And I was like, yeah, we don't really play music.
I can't do background music.
As if music's on, I want to lean in and listen to it.
And I can't switch that part of my brain off.
So then Kerry doesn't like having music in the house
because I just stop having a conversation.
Like if music comes on, I just...
And she'll be like, you've gone.
I was like, oh, sorry, let's turn it off then, I guess.
And then when you listen to it, do you,
do you analyze it, the chord progressions, the melodies?
Yeah, yeah, normally, you know,
and a lot of the time, then sort of store it to try and copy it, you know.
Yeah, sure, sure.
Do you listen to a lot of new music at all?
Yeah, yeah, I listen to probably mostly new music, actually,
and if I'm on my own, that's when I listen to music.
And how are you finding the new stuff?
Is somebody giving you tips on like, oh, you should check this out?
Or how about this, you know, all those streaming services, they like, they figure out what you like and then they send you suggestions and stuff.
Do you find that helpful? Do you follow some of those?
Sometimes, some of my favorite music I've found on TikTok when I was on it.
And now I'm not on it.
My new music has dried up a bit, actually.
I was enjoying that.
There's an amazing British band called Divorce, a great band name, who became my new favorite obsession.
I was completely obsessed with them,
and we got them to come on tour with us,
which was fun.
But I just found the algorithm, you know, fed them to me.
So you found them and said,
hey, let's get these guys come on tour with us.
Yeah, and then we ended up recording a song together.
Oh, that's great.
I love that.
Wait, you had to cut yourself off from TikTok?
Is that when I'm sniffing out?
I did, yeah.
I just, well, I did it ahead of putting out the new record
because I just wanted to be insulated
from how other people felt about it,
because I knew how I felt about it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And I didn't need some, like, comment somewhere, spoiling my experience
because I was happy with it.
Good for you.
And I couldn't change it.
It was done.
And this is the first time I've ever put a record out where I genuinely have not read a word about it.
And I feel free.
I love that.
That's cool.
It's cool.
I mean, it's a privilege, obviously, but it's cool.
So other people do our socials and stuff.
And, you know, we send stuff over and we think about it.
We're intentional about it.
But I don't have to do any of it or be on any of it, which is cool.
You must come across, you must come across bands and stuff.
when you're touring too, or if you do a festival,
do you, like, all of a sudden, do you find yourself going,
oh, wait, what is that going on over there
and, like, and hear somebody that way?
Does that ever happen?
Yeah, yeah, and a lot of the time, it's just recommendations from mates, you know.
They're like, you should listen to this.
And sometimes when we're discussing who to come on the road,
one of us will pipe up with something we've been listening to,
you know, because we're very intentional about who comes out
and supports us on tour.
Because those are the shows I go to now.
Yeah, right, mostly.
And I'll go, and every night I don't like,
playing a show without watching the support band
first because it just gets me in the mood and it
makes me feel what the room's like. Yeah, of course.
Yeah. There's a new English band
that I've been obsessed with, West Side Cowboy.
Have you heard these guys? Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So fucking good, man.
Didn't they support Geese on their
run? Oh, did they? I think they support.
Yeah, them and Dav Ellis. So that
I found Dav Ellis through Geese
because I knew he was on the road with
them. And I'm
like, you know, the rest of the internet
obsessed with them. And
And yeah, that's how I found Davellis.
So a lot of the time it's just like, who's playing with who
and these little communities that pop up,
which we were part of when we first started as a band.
And that's really how people discovered us
because they'd come to a Laura Marley.
That's how Carrie found out about it.
She booked a ticket to a Laura Marling show.
And then we started shouting sort of an hour before Laura went on.
And then she was like, oh, Mumford, I knew a kid called Mumford.
And that's so I love those little communities still, you know.
Yeah, yeah.
She left a note with our tour manager.
She didn't come backstage.
No, she left a note.
See, that's classic.
That's really classy.
Wait, so I'm embarrassed.
She probably told us this, I apologize for forgetting.
So on the note, did she say,
hey, so I did know this guy named Mumford.
I forget his first name.
Is his name?
No, do you know what?
We were both, I guess, on Facebook for like a six-month window
when I was still at college,
and we connected there.
And then this was like a couple years after that
when we'd started the band.
and I was still playing in Laura's band.
And so she left a note with our tour manager
with her email address on it, I think.
Wow.
So knowing that it was you, once she saw you on stage, maybe?
Yeah, yeah.
It's great.
You know what's great about this, Marcus, but also email,
not the phone number.
Just another layer.
You know what I mean?
Slow play, real classy.
She's a classy broad.
A classy broad.
When did you know that music might actually be
a path towards a living for you
as opposed to just fun.
Still not convinced.
Still in some state of arrested development.
What a base.
Now that was a band.
For Sean, that's a TV show that was on.
I gotta write that show.
For Sean.
I think...
Is it playing now?
Was also a good band.
I think it's like...
I was at college.
I got offered a job playing music.
I wasn't having a great time at college,
so I stopped.
and took a sabbatical.
Where'd you go to college?
And I think Edinburgh.
And I think in my head I'm still on my...
Until quite recently, I've been on my sabbatical from college.
Sure, sure.
I mean thinking that you would probably go back?
Yeah.
And what would you have studied if you'd gone back?
I was doing classics.
I was doing Greek and Latin.
What, literature?
To do what?
Unclear.
You know, it's not a vocational...
No, it isn't.
Just reading?
Reading?
It's what a lot of lawyers.
To be a monk?
Yeah.
Classics in the UK particularly
is seen as like a good, honest,
old school degree to do
if you're doing something.
But what do you do with that?
I don't understand.
He said lawyers, yeah?
Oh, lawyer.
Well, what's cool about it as a...
Come a member of parliament.
Yeah, a lot of those.
A lot of prime ministers do it.
But I wasn't on that track.
What's cool about it is
it gives you access to poetry
and philosophy and storytelling and language and linguistics,
anthropology, ancient history,
all these things that you study through the original languages.
Jason, you're drooling.
Your mouth is up on your drool.
So it's really geeky, and you get your geek goggles out when you're talking about.
I bet it helps you when you write lyrics.
And it's how I got introduced to poetry.
It's how I fell in love with words, honestly.
And then I started reading T.S. Eliot really pretentiously as like a 17-year-old
And suddenly words had a new depth to them.
And, you know, he was a classicist too.
And the references, a lot of classical references,
and I'd sort of read a bit of Homer and then switch over to Elliot
and be like, oh, cool, look at the way he's joined up
and referred back to this.
Can't you just see 17-year-old Marx just riding a bicycle
through some field and then just like dropping into a field
and reading poetry?
Yeah, with a bad cat and a basket on the bike.
I was that guy. I was sat on the train to Edinburgh
I wore a thick fabric and a collar that I cut the collar off my shirt
because I'd seen the assassination of Jesse James
and just got deep into poetry.
And honestly, until this last record,
I've been in denial about that too.
You know, I've been in this process of being like,
this is kind of who I am now, this is what I do.
So for Prize Fighter, I'd go and sit in the coffee shops
in Hudson, New York,
because we were recording with Aaron Destin at Longpond,
and I'd sit in the coffee shop for two hours every morning,
and I'd do my artist's way, like, morning pages,
and I'd sit and read poetry like a real twat
and just really lent in to, I guess, my identity at this point,
and it helped me write lyrics, you know.
Let's hit Babel for a second here.
So what did the incredible success of that album do for you?
personally, like, was it jarring to sort of have that next step of success and recognition and treasure?
And like, was it, did you adapt well to that?
Was it, was it a fun thing or was it a bit disruptive?
That's a great question, actually.
Thank you.
Finally for once.
I don't think anyone, unless you may be one of Simon Cowell's projects, I don't think you're trained.
you know, to have that kind of level of success.
We started playing music because we loved playing.
We loved each other.
And it was just fun.
And we got free beers.
And then suddenly, we were playing 250 shows a year.
And then suddenly, you know, the first record starts gaining some pace.
We took six weeks off tour to make Babel,
which our producer at the time was really frustrated about.
He's like, why do you have shows booked on the other side of a recording process
that's really dumb,
creatively but we rushed it
and I think we got it right but it
was pressurized and then
the success of that
record around the world really
and particularly in the States
just opened us up to a world
we weren't like ever anticipating
or planning for
and
yeah
I mean I don't think unless
you're a kind of pop project
you're even imagining
it and then suddenly
the shows are all selling out
and you're moving into bigger spaces
and fulfilling lots of your dreams as a kid
like to headline Glastonbury
we only did on two records
I remember getting at the end of the set
we basically had to play the whole of both records
to fill the time
and I remember getting the end of the set
and just being like, we just need more songs man
that's all we got
we need more songs because you watch
Springsteen play for three hours and he's playing like
just hit after hit after hit
yeah yeah
so yeah I
I wasn't really prepared for the success of that record.
And I think we reacted to it a bit by making a record on the third one that no one was expecting from us.
No one particularly wanted, but we loved it.
And it took us into bigger rooms as well.
And that was how it went widescreen.
And then the fourth record.
And then we had a long gap before the fifth and sixth records.
Yeah.
How long was that gap?
That was like on paper.
It was seven years.
I mean, we were touring for two of those after Delta came out and then COVID happened.
Yeah.
So we were a part as a band for maybe three years, yeah.
That's what was that biggest adjustment there when that first wave of big success came in?
I mean, obviously most notable would be the bigger crowds and the sellouts
and it would probably be nicer hotels and you're flying from city to city instead of the buses maybe
or just silly things like that.
But it must have been pretty heady too, right?
You're watching people, you know, sing your songs en masse.
and probably getting some feedback as to how you're affecting people and changing their lives a bit.
And, you know, probably a weaker, more insecure person would probably buy into that a lot and kind of own a lot of that.
I'll bet you sort of deflected a bit of that and tried to keep it all about the music and keep it simple.
But you tell me.
It drove a bit of my shame narrative that was already there that I've looked,
at a little bit. I drank a bit more than probably I should have.
Like imposter kind of stuff?
Yeah, a bit of that. Yeah, a bit of that for sure.
And I went in a bit.
And on stage, you'd be very out, you know, give yourself completely.
And then my friendship circle shrunk a bit.
Yeah.
I think, yeah, I did use booze, particularly as a bit of an escape.
and then really throughout it all honestly my marriage has just been the best thing about everything
yeah yeah so but i think as we get older it all it's sort of naturally and in a very healthy way i
think most people that circle gets smaller you figure out more accurately who you are and what the
what the what the proper fits are for you and that usually equates to a smaller more specific
more precise experience with people.
Right?
You're not out there shopping as much for...
Yeah, and I think I recognize the idea of capacity.
Yeah.
Because for a few years there particularly,
I was spread really thin.
I mean, you guys must find this with your jobs as well.
You meet so many people,
and a lot of them you love,
and then you want to be friends with,
and then you connect with other people,
and then I found myself getting spread really thinly
and not being very good friends to my friends.
Right.
and then that shrinking happened a bit.
So in a kind of healthy way, I think.
So I guess it's, yeah, I think you're right.
It's partly growing up.
But yeah, I suppose I dealt with it all in a bit of unhealthy ways.
Then I stopped drinking booze more out of choice than necessity,
although, you know, we could debate that.
And then replaced it with ice cream for a while
until I was told, you know, I wasn't losing any weight.
It was really confused about the whole day.
We have similar paths in that way
I did that route too
where it was like an ice cream-based diet
after I quit booze
Yeah
Because you miss the sugar
I remember that
Yeah I miss it too
Wait Marcus
You know I'm always kind of interested
Probably been an hour
At least
I'm like starting to shake
You know I'm always interested
When people like you
who have bands and you tell me,
did you have vocal training or know any,
or how to use your voice or because when I go,
for example, I'm a massive Depeche Mode fan.
They came out on the podcast.
It was really wild.
I'm also a huge fan of yours and I love all kinds of music too.
And I went to go see Dave Gahan sing and I can tell right away,
oh, he didn't warm up.
And then after the first couple songs,
his voice kind of opened up a little bit and then it was great.
great and it was great from the beginning too but just kept reach out and touch faith
and then do you do did you have any kind of training or did you realize when you were touring like
oh shit i don't know how to take care of the kind of athleticism of my voice yeah i i was convinced
for years that whiskey and cigarettes really helped yeah right and then just recently i've
started actually brandy carl introduced me to her
vocal coach, guy called Rob Stevenson,
who's totally changed
my world and giving me some education
on stuff.
Like, it's a muscle and you have to warm it up.
And I've been lucky
not to, and I watched friends around me get
affected by the Palleps thing and losing their voices.
We've never, I don't think
we've cancelled a show for my voice
in the past. Which has been
cool. Like the only couple of shows that I remember
cancelling were because Ted had a
had a brain hemorrhage.
Oh, jeez.
Which wasn't funny at all.
Get up.
But now is quite funny because he had to wear a hat for a while.
But he headlined Glastonbury two weeks after getting that surgery, like a legend.
And I think we cancelled two shows for that.
But we've just been lucky and my voice has been resilient.
Amazing.
But I think recently I've realised it's a muscle.
Now I start, and now I have a full routine and I look after it.
I quit smoking and all that stuff.
Oh, good, good, good.
And we will be right back.
And back to the show.
What does that mean about the polyps?
Because I had polyps removed from my vocal cords,
but it means you're weak psychologically.
Oh, damn it.
Yeah, it's the piano lesson thing.
It's because it's a piano,
your parents were right.
It was character development.
Yeah, what a shame.
No, but I think the doctor did say that I wasn't using my voice correctly
because I was like screaming in bars.
and smoking cigarettes and stuff.
And he said, I just, I wrecked it that way.
Is that what happens to musicians or to singers
that don't know how to warm up correctly?
You can create polyps on your vocal cords?
I honestly don't know.
I think the wear and tear of it, is it, is true.
Yeah.
I know that, like, going out after show,
I just don't ever do that anymore
because talking in loud rooms after shows
is the thing that is worse for your voice.
Right.
So after a show, I don't go on voice rest.
I'm not like precious about it.
Right.
But I don't go out.
And I stay away from a loud place.
Well, you also have a wife you love and three kids
that you've got to go spend time with too, you know?
Also, I've just become quite boring and monkish, you know.
Jason, Amanda ever developed poplops?
Oh, boy.
I'm screaming.
That's your date.
I know.
I love her.
more than anything in the whole world.
Hey, so...
I lost my voice two days ago, actually, a little bit.
Really?
Yeah.
Too bad you found it.
Wait, Will, have you ever checked out?
Go ahead.
Jay.
I lost mine two weeks ago.
Yeah, it's still weak.
I still...
Like, if I ever did theater, I'd have a real...
I would need to take real lessons about how to use my house.
Have you not done theater?
No.
I mean, tiny, small room stuff.
But, like, if I ever did it, you know, here in New York,
I'd lead to help.
Jay, I was thinking the same thing.
Yesterday, I didn't fully lose it, but I was really close,
and I thought, I was just thinking about you, Sean,
and about how you've been basically on stage
for the last three years, kind of straight.
Yeah, and Marcus, you must have the same thing.
And I thought, I'm going through this thing of like,
I wouldn't, if I were in a play right now, I'd be fucked.
I wouldn't be able to be able to do it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, you really have to take care of it.
And, Sean, do you do, like, a full hour every night before you?
Yeah, and there's songs that I'll sing to one.
Like if I know if I'll sing all by myself and if I can hit that high note.
Let's have it.
All by my...
Then I can do the whole show.
Sick.
You know what I mean?
It's funny. And you usually do it through tears, right?
Right.
No, that's the song because it was a one-man show, so I would sing all by myself.
Uh-huh.
Marcus, do you have a go-to little thing that you do for warm-up?
Like a little scale thing or something like that?
Yeah, I do.
It's called The Penguin Noise.
It's a lot of this.
that's good yeah really yeah and then vocal straws i use straws it's about like i mean we could get
teckers if you want but it's about getting your larynx to drop back down like they're putting your
tongue at the back of your throat and opening your palate with a straw literally with a straw
and then the straw the straw helps with back pressure so you blow bubbles into a into a bottle through a
straw and then the back pressure helps open that up and easel that out it's like a little
reverse massage do you ever actually do you ever accidentally throw up do you ever accidentally throw up
when you're doing it i i can't eat like four hours before we go on stage because then bits come up
yeah yeah yeah because it's all quite shouty you know yeah yeah that's why i'm just you accidentally
throw up after a lot of big meals don't you yeah oh oh darn it but i hold his hair i hold his hair i've got to
get it out inside 10 minutes, otherwise it starts to absorb the fat.
So, Marcus, Marcus, we're a month into your tour.
What will have been the most important part of your prep to go on some long tour?
Like, do you have to get, you know, your family stuff all in order so that it can withstand you being gone so long long?
Do you have to get your body in order
so it can withstand the hours?
What is prep for a long tour look at?
I have been trying to approach.
I got to a point a couple years ago,
I was like, there is an element of physicality to my job
that requires me to train a bit more.
So I have been working on that
and trying to approach it more like an athletics program
and everything else will follow
if I can do that stuff well.
What are we looking at?
Cardio, we're pushing weight.
What's our terms?
training the play.
Yeah, all that stuff.
Yeah, and then we have a little gym on the road that helps.
There's a lot of card.
Like singing, it turns out that singing playing guitar and stamping like this with your feet,
which you must remember, Jason, from that video.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, Jay was in the video.
So fun.
That stuff turns out is some sort of cardio.
I used to think it was enough to.
Yeah, it's exhausting.
Wait, talk about how did that happen?
How did Jason, how did Jason, how did Jason,
Baitman end up in your video.
Less disdain.
No, I spit it out.
How did fucking Jason Bateman end up.
It was all, it was a friend Sam Jones, wasn't it?
He called you.
Oh, yeah.
Or was it Sadecas?
I think maybe I was doing horrible bosses at the time.
Maybe it was, I'll bet you Sam contacted.
I didn't know Sam, so he wouldn't have contacted me.
So it would have been probably Sadecas or Ed or Will.
Yeah.
And then they, I don't know how they got to me.
It must have got a lot of passes before they got to me.
But God, that was so fun.
Probably my favorite music video we've ever done
because I didn't have to do anything.
And I just got to watch you guys do it.
It was absolutely amazing.
Forte killed me on that.
Oh yeah, well, Farte was in.
With a kiss, the kiss.
The kiss, the hard kiss.
All right, so that brings us to Sam.
That brings us to the dock.
Let's talk about the dock.
Let's talk about the train tour.
Let's talk about you arranging.
for those other groups
because you spoke earlier about picking
the bands that you guys
are interfacing with.
Well, let's go in order.
What's it like traveling on a train that long
with that many people?
It's really exhausting.
I don't recommend it.
It's very confined.
It's like being on a submarine.
It's worse than a tour bus.
Right.
And I mean, it was the most...
Sorry, tell the audience what the basic concept of this thing.
And it was inspired by the...
This happened, Woody Guthrie.
and gang, right?
Yeah, I think they did it.
Basically, someone came to us, you know,
I don't know, 2011 and said,
we have access to a bunch of vintage rail cars.
Do you want to go on tour on a train?
Yeah.
And we, at that point, we're like,
we'd just done a tour of India.
Yeah.
Well before we had any reason to do a tour of India.
You know, we'd toured on a narrow boat.
We liked putting up our own festivals.
It was just, like, fun ways of, like,
making the shit feel slightly different.
and discovering bits of the world
that you might not otherwise.
So we were feeling adventurous
and we said, yes, we did it with Edward Sharp
and the Magnetic Zeros.
With old Crow Medicine show
and it was the best week on the road we've ever had.
And we made a film and it won a Grammy
and we were all very happy.
It was great.
And so we thought, let's run it back
slightly differently.
Let's get all our favorite musicians
together as a house band.
And then every night we'll get special guests
to come on stage with us.
So we had Lainey, Wilson,
Harris, Rucker, Maggie Rogers, and Noah Kahn.
And we learned their songs the day before.
Wow.
And performed like the house band for them.
And it was really fun.
And we did it.
Yeah, we traveled by train.
But that's not really the audience participation part,
because obviously it was just us and crew that went on the trains.
But it was only five days.
So it was manageable.
But it was exhausting.
But you've got Sam and his gang with the cameras in there documenting the, yeah?
Yeah, so Sam made this film for it, which I really love, actually.
I don't enjoy the process of making music films.
I think in general they're quite boring, and I don't really watch them for pleasure.
And this one...
It can feel like a reality show, right?
Yeah, a little bit.
And, yeah, I find it quite hard to relate to a lot of them.
Obviously, the Beatles one is my favorite of all time, and I've watched that many times.
But other than that, I don't get a huge amount of enjoyment from watching.
This one, especially not our ones.
But this one, I actually think he did something really beautiful with,
and the people involved were unbelievably kind with their time.
We made it kind of like a socialistic enterprise.
Everyone got paid the same,
and whatever cash there was left in the pot
after very expensive trains, we just shared out.
And then our friends really gave us their time, you know,
and they're phenomenal musicians, and we had it a working time.
I was going to say for Tracy,
but she knows because she met Sam
when we went to her. Sam Jones is the same guy
who did the Smartless on the road
special that we did.
So that's how we all know Sam
through the process.
Yeah, that's so cool.
I didn't know he did this
and I didn't know anything about this.
When can we see it?
And I'd made a film with him before.
He made the documentary about the new basement tapes thing
that we did with Elvis Costello
and Jim James and Taylor Bosman.
Oh, I don't know about this.
Yeah, and Giddens.
We took old Bob Dylan lyrics
that Tebow and Burnett had like pilfered off Dylan.
and asked if we could record music for them
and Dylan amazingly said yes
they were literally from shoe boxes
and the Big Pink from the 60s
and so we wrote music to all these unused lyrics
which was really fun
and Sam made a documentary of that
so I'd worked with him before
and obviously he shot our Rolling Stone cover
which I hate but he also made that Hopeless Wanderer video
that Jason was in so we'd work with him a bit before
and he came on and did it and it was sweet
and he also made the Wilco Dock
I'm trying to break your heart
Yeah, which is also amazing.
It's so great.
It's so good.
I want to see that talk you were just talking about.
I want to see that one where you guys with the diligence.
Oh, it's sweet.
Yeah, it was a while ago.
Yeah, too, actually.
Go ahead, Cheney.
I was just going to do my standard, like,
do you have any like one show or one fan interaction on stage
that just went horribly wrong,
or something that went horribly wrong on stage during a tour?
Yeah, yeah, recently.
We started the Prize Fighter tour in Australia.
Yeah.
And we played a song for the first time
and it went so badly wrong,
we stopped halfway through,
and we didn't start the song again.
No way.
I love that, though.
Oh, my God, I love that.
What did you say?
I said, that's live music, folks, and we moved on.
And I wanted to fall through the floor so badly.
It was the worst, I think it was the worst moment I've ever, ever had on.
Why did you stop?
Oh, it was just a disaster.
Everyone was in the wrong key and wrong time.
Oh, wow.
a disaster and would have required a full rehearsal to do it.
And I thought that was probably pushing it.
So we just stopped and moved on to one there.
And you just thought, we'll get this, we'll get this, watch this, six, seven, eight.
It was awful. It was so horrible.
I'll bet you the audience loved it though, like kind of, you know, like a blooper.
Yeah, that's so cool.
Yeah, I think, you know, yeah, my wife says things like, because I forget lyrics a lot.
When I get nervous, my memory goes, and I'll forget a lyric sometimes, and she'll be like,
that's the bit people love.
Yeah. That's the live bit as different to the original.
record and...
I toured with Kenny Rogers when I was in my early 20s
as a Christmas elf in his tour.
Amazing.
And he would forget the lyrics all the time.
And whenever he did, he would just hold the microphone out to the audience.
You got to know when.
I thought...
Sean, I thought you'd go, hey, Santa, the lyric is.
Yeah, shuffle over like a little helpful elf.
Hey, have you ever done that on stage, though?
Because that's, that terrifies, especially with a one-man show.
Have you ever forgotten your lives?
Yeah, yeah.
There's one, I just did it.
It's absolutely terrifying.
There is one part where the line is, you know, I say to one of the characters, I say,
are you going to be here?
How long are you in town for?
And he says, the weekend.
I say, can we get together and discuss this one thing?
He says, sure.
And then I say, your last name is DuPain.
And then one night I go, is one of the characters.
I go, how long are you in town for?
He goes, the weekend.
And I go, can we get together?
and I go
to myself
I go wait how long
are you in town for
to the character
and I go
I just told you
I'm in town
just for the weekend
and it bought me time
to think of what line was next
and did you get there
yeah thank God
and do you think people noticed
no they don't fucking know
yeah
and certainly the stage manager
that was asleep in the wings
not throwing you the line
didn't notice
either, right?
Right, yeah.
They just watch.
The living daylight's happening.
Yeah, it is pretty good.
All right, before we let you go, because we're two minutes over here, I want to know how
being a parent has changed the way that you, that you listen to music or write music.
I'm assuming they go with you a little bit, but it's got to change the way you are as an artist,
as a musician, yes?
Yeah.
Yeah, I think it's, I think it's been a healthy, I think it's been a wonderful antidote to my
narcissism.
because you can't just
you can't just be the cent
I mean you probably can
but I found it difficult
to remain the centre of my universe
with these little ones around
and it puts everything else in perspective
in such a helpful way for me
I've found it
so if you're asking about how it's
how it's affected my work
it makes me more intentional when I go to work
and actually scheduling wise
I just want our team to pack as much
as they can into as short a period of time as possible.
So I'll go away and I'll work really, really hard for whatever period of time I'm away,
and then I'd come home and sooner than I would have, if the schedule had been more easy, you know?
And I would imagine when you do come home, that is the thing you are most addicted to
completely indulging in, right?
You are rationally excited to just like dive headfirst into family.
Yeah, I want to get home, you know, like one of the guys really likes,
doing the day,
I just want to get home
as soon as possible
I don't care which flight it is
and then hopefully be there
for the school run the morning after
because, and that's why
dropping booze for me
has been so helpful,
it's just made my life more functional.
Get up earlier.
Because I get home, I'm not dusty.
You know, I'm like,
yeah, it's just being like present
as fast as you can
in an accelerated manner, it feels like.
So it's made me more present, I think.
Yeah, yeah.
And then more grateful when I get to go
and do my work and
go and play these shows.
I just feel grateful for it. I'm in this
season of gratitude with the band that I'm just
really enjoying because I'll go
away and be like, I've got to make the absolute
most of this because it's
awesome and it's amazing. It's such a privilege
and our audience have been so
kind to us and continue to grow and
that's just felt like
wild and so I want to
be really good. I want to be really
great at that and that takes
time and attention that
obviously is a cost balance, you know.
But I'm just attacking it.
Well, you are, you want to read out and work.
Sorry, Jay, I was just going to say, like, I've gone through that too in the last couple of years.
It's like if you are going to do something that's taking you away from home and the kids and all this stuff, it's got to be valuable.
Exactly.
And if you're going to do it, you do it wholeheartedly.
And then you go, because you really just want to be home.
Right.
So it's got to be meaningful.
Well, we're grateful of the time you do spend
away from them because you are incredible at it.
Keep going at it.
And maybe we'll see you for the doc down the street.
I will see you.
With my wife.
The woman he'll be with is my wife.
And I want a full report, Marcus.
Take some pictures for me.
I'm really excited to see you guys.
Yeah.
Thanks so much for having me.
Oh, thank you.
for doing this.
Privilege.
Oh, man.
We're such fans.
Enjoy the rest of your day, Val.
Thank you, see you guys.
Okay, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye.
That was double M, as I like to call him.
Double M&M.
I call him M&M.
It was great.
By the way, isn't that crazy
that at the beginning, we were talking about our hair
and you said, what's the name of your new hairdresser?
And I said, Marcos.
No, it's not.
Marcos.
Marcos Mumford.
Yeah, I just,
I just don't think that's Mark.
And then the guest name was Mark.
Well, it's M-I-R-C-O-S.
So it's the same.
I get where you're going with this, Sean.
But, you know, it's not, it's not fucking nuts.
It's not crazy.
No.
I think that's really wild.
I mean, what are the odds of that?
What are the odds?
He's great, though.
I mean...
Chat TB-T, what are the odds?
He is great.
That I didn't, you know, I never knew anything about him.
I like, I really like his...
flavor of British accent.
Yeah, me too.
I noticed that too, and I like that too.
It's melodious.
Yeah, it's nice.
It's calming.
There are definitely different regions of the British accent.
Oh, which ones aren't there, Jason?
There's sort of the aristocratic sound.
There's the Liverpadlian, there's the slightly Scottish, there's the Welsh, right?
Will, Will, you're the guy over there.
How dare you?
Oh, very dear, yeah.
Right?
And, like, I wouldn't be...
You're okay.
You're right, Jason.
Yeah, see?
You can't just do a regular British accent
if you're going to play a character.
It's got to be region-specific.
Yep.
He's such a nice dude.
I'm really excited for the doc.
I can't wait to see it.
I didn't know anything about it.
Yeah, yeah.
It's going to be really good.
What time are you going to pick my wife up?
And what are you going to wear?
Well, she's spending the night,
so I think that we're going to...
Hang on.
We're going to be, we'll just get ready together, you know.
By the way, I was just talking to her right before this.
She says, hello, Jason.
Oh, yeah, I've not spoken to her yet today.
You guys really do more time on the phone than me.
We can decide if we want to cut this.
I said, are we doing dinner on Sunday?
She goes, I'm not sure.
And if we don't do dinner, I go, well, we can get dinner.
She goes, no, if we're not doing dinner with all of us getting together,
I'm doing a full moon women's circle, L.O.L.
Hold your tongue.
Full moon, women's circle.
There is some kind of a full, full light bulb up in the sky coming up here soon.
How about that?
Wait, and what are you doing the circle?
I'll call her.
I don't know.
Maybe I'll do that.
Yeah, we'll trim this.
All right.
Who's got a buy?
Anybody got a buy?
Wait, didn't I try to start something new last week?
If we ever did a week where we didn't throw out a buy, we would have to call that the
Bye week.
The bye week we get a bye.
I don't need to keep saying it.
Smartless is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Rob Armjurf, Bennett, Barbico, and Michael Grant Terry.
Smartless.